let's say that armand today
is 18 years old
18 years old and let's say that dia
dia today
is two
two years old
and what i am curious about in this
video
is how many years will it take and let
me write this down how
many
years
will it take
for
arman
for armand to be
three times
times
as old
as dia
as dia so that's the question right
there and i encourage you to try to take
a shot at this yourself
so let's think about this a little bit
we're asking how many years will it take
that's what we don't know that's what
we're curious about how many years will
it take for armand to be three times as
old as dia so let's set
let's set some variable let's say y for
years let's say y is equal to years
years it
will take
so given that can we now set up an
equation given this information to
figure out how many years it will take
for armand to be three times as old as
dia
well let's think about how how old arman
will be in y years how old will he be
well in y years let me write it here in
in y
years
armand
armand is going to be how old arman is
going to be well he's 18 right now
and in y years he's going to be y years
older so in y years armand is going to
be 18 plus y
and what about dia
how old will she be
how old will she be in y years
well she's two now and in y here she'll
just be 2
plus y
so what we're curious about now that we
know this is how many years it will take
for
this quantity for this expression to be
3 times this quantity so we're really
curious
we want to solve for y such that 18 plus
y
is going to be equal to 3 times
is going to be equal to 3 times 2 plus y
3 times 2 plus y notice this is our mod
and y years this is d and y years and
we're saying that what our month is
going to be in y years is three times
what dia is going to be in y years so
we've set up our equation now we can
just solve it so let's take this step by
step
so on the left hand side and maybe i'll
do this in a new color just so i don't
have to keep switching so the left hand
side i still have 18 plus y and on the
right hand side i can distribute this 3.
so 3 times 2 is 6
3 times y is 3y 6 plus 3
y
and then it's always nice to get all of
our constants on one side of the
equation all of our variables on the
other side of the equation so let's we
have a 3y over here we have more y's on
the right hand side than the left-hand
side so let's get rid of the y's on the
left-hand side you could do it either
way but you would end up with negative
numbers so let's subtract a y from each
side
and we are left with
we are left with on the left hand side
and on the right hand side you have six
plus three y's take away one of those
y's you're going to be left with two y's
now we can get rid of the constant term
here
so we will subtract 6 from both sides
subtract 6 from both sides 18 minus 6 is
12. the whole reason why we subtracted 6
from the right was to get rid of this 6
minus 6 is 0. so you have 12 is equal to
2y
2 times the number of years it will take
is 12 and you could probably solve this
in your head but if we just want a 1
coefficient here we would divide by 2 on
the right whatever we do to one side of
equation we have to do it on the other
side otherwise the equation will not
still be an equation
so we are left with
we are left with
y
is equal to 6 or y is equal to 6.
so
going back to the question how many
years will it take for armand to be
three times as old as dia well it's
going to take
six
years
now i want you to verify this think
about it is this actually true
well in six years how old are going to
be he's going to be 18 plus six we now
know that this thing is six so in
in six years in six years armand is
going to be 18 plus 6 which is 24 years
old how old is dia gonna be
well she's going to be 2 plus 6
which is
2 plus 6 which is 8 years old and lo and
behold 24 is indeed three times as old
as eight in in six years armand's 24 d
is eight armand is three times as old as
dia and we are done